no I just I just like I I know like I I
know that you were an interesting cat so
it's like I'd love to do this not what
you expected right no I I just like well
I know I expect something along the
lines of what you were but you exceeded
that yeah and I know you've got more
stories so that's why I'd love to bring
you back so here we are yeah so so we
didn't really talk much about your
father we were talking about it just now
yes I I love just give me a brief
overview of of who your dad was oh we
don't need to name any names or anything
like that just but just who your father
was as a man as a person yeah little
synopsis how his life involved and
whatever his father was killed your
father was Joe Columbo head of the
Columbo crime family that's what you say
I say it was that of the Columbo family
okay got it all right yeah I've watched
I mean this this whole crime thing is
read articles I'm a bookmaker it was
illegal then it's legal today you know
he was involved in policy it was illegal
then it's legal today so what his vice
today commers tomorrow I stand corrected
yeah so you know what is crime if that's
the case the United States government is
by farly the biggest crime family that
ever existed with no ethics or morals
quite well made what whatsoever they
don't care who they destroy you know and
uh it's actually pretty sad when you
think about it because the tactics they
use and the things they did was you know
gambling is a harmless Vice there's no
victims there and and the nonsense that
people hit gamblers is that true it
would be like me coming in through an
interview and you wanted me back and
then stabing me in the heart when leave
I mean how good is that for your
business I mean it just doesn't make
sense you kill off your customers or
kill your viewers you know figure out
something to put in there or destroy
them they'd be a bad review so uh but
you you speak about your dad very highly
not because he was my dad
uh there's certain standards that he
instilled in us from birth and the way
he did like I did with my son and he had
those
standards and and that's why I say the
ethics and morals of people that time
especially him uh coming out of a
depression coming out of World War II
you know they they went through things
that people don't go through you know
and uh his family ethics and his his
country ethics everybody thought he was
anti-government no he was prover and
wanted the government to serve the
people and uh he had a way of speaking
to you and when he spoke to
you it was actually amazing excuse me I
drank Starbucks Coffee it was a rough
one that was up on night uh we had a
long TR in here I have two more
interviews after this this one's a
pleasure because first before I continue
I'd like to thank everybody I don't
watch the videos but I do watch the
comments they were very very kind and
secondly you made a very good choice by
following Mark I mean uh I mean you see
his work but you don't know how good his
energy is and how much he enjoys it and
what a pleasure he is to be interviewed
by and uh he has a way also of bringing
out the best in people people have their
own inate natural talents and my father
had that you he was a natural leader he
had a sense of humor and he had a way of
protecting the weak and he didn't like
Abus of power that was his number one
thing but he was evolutionary not
revolutionary in his tactics unless you
know he was in danger he endangered his
family you know that's who he was it's
who I am it's what every person should
be uh when you say tough a tough guy I
mean guys you know I don't run around
talking tough to people I talk
empathetically compassionately and
understanding to them and the only time
you should be tough is when it's time to
be tough somebody's looking to harm you
or harm your kids so you know he was
very against TV and journalism and and
and even radio and talk shows portraying
Italians in that manner and people
started acting like the movies and the
journalists because they thought that's
the way they should act people to some
degree emulate what they see in the
media and it was very destructive you
know we got into that the word mafia
does not exist they don't call
themselves that and uh it's just an
ethnic SL to paint the brush now what is
organized crime it's a conspiracy theory
because there's only two countries in
the world that have the conspiracy law
the United States and Great Britain but
Great Britain only has it with a plot
against the royal family so three
Italians on a corner is a
conspiracy uh we did very kind deeds and
he played the hand he was dealt the way
it should be played if it was played to
be dealt as a man he dealt it as a man
it was played to be a gentleman deled is
a gentleman I never forget when I was in
second grade I always heard that you
should always be a gentleman now did I
know what a gentleman was in second
grade no did not so teacher asked the
class you know what would you like to be
some people said fireman some people
said police officers some people said
lawyers some people said doctors some
people said veterinarian
you know I said I wanted to be a
gentleman you know and the teachers you
know teacher took notice to that but if
I could explain to you what a gentleman
was verbally I couldn't but I witnessed
it growing up and what a gentleman is is
a man that handles his situations in a
proper way and there's also a thing
called unsung
gentleman's and that's a guy that does
it quietly and whatever uh and not
looking for Glory and uh he was an sung
gentleman when he needed to be and then
he was very visible and vocal when he
had to be so but I would call him an
unsung gentleman he was always there
working on making you better you had to
be better to your
capabilities you know he used to say and
he was very Advanced if the most you
have to give is 30% you did 30% put your
head on the pillow you did the best you
can you'll be treated like you gave 100%
cuz it's all you had to give so I grew
up with those type of
things and you got to remember I didn't
go fight at World War II I wasn't on a
suicide mission I wasn't stationed in
casablanc I didn't grow up during the
Depression I didn't come home to a you
know starving situation where you
couldn't earn a living and if you're
hustle learning numbers or or taking a
bet I mean I don't think it's the worst
thing in
America they're doing it now and they're
going to destroy this country that's why
I'm doing the podcast taking action with
Chris Columbo because I see one of the
stories I'm going to tell you of the
pitfalls of it and I ran up like a
corporation if you made 500 a week
follow me there was no way I was letting
you lose
$5,000 you follow me if you made a th000
a week the most you could bet on a week
was a th000 if you lost it and not a
game only 100 a game to give you the
action if you lost it I would shut you
down till you paid it if you had to pay
it 100 a week for 10 weeks or 100 a
month for 10 months I didn't care or
however you had to pay it and when I
used to say if you if you miss one
vacation a with your kids not a pair of
shoes miss a meal or can't pay the rent
we'll work it out even if it takes 10
years doesn't matter to me at no
interest so that's why I had the
customer base I did that's why I had the
reactions I did you know are there
people out there that let a person
working shop right that or Walmart lose
$50,000 that earn 300 a week yeah are
they ever going to get paid no so it's
the illusion then not the reality of it
now legalized gambling it's going to
change a lot of things because like I
have said there is that addictive gene
and because it's illegal you don't
saturate that market or see it now
you're going to see it so they have
these kids betting paray and they say
somebody bet 46 cents on a par and won
465,000 that may have happened but right
now sitting here I'd have a better shout
and we're in New York City at the W
Hotel of a shark swimming into the
brackish water up the the East River
jumping into the sewer and coming out a
bowl and biting me but what they're
trying to do is if you have $1,000 to
bet they'll take it if you got 46 cents
to bet you take it that's a dangerous
thing and they're sell a dream so I'm
trying to show them how to survive how
to bet I I am an expert at it and how to
analyze how to think with their mind and
how to do it as a science rather than an
addiction or a compulsive marketing
tactic and what compelled me to do that
was I watched my son his friends would
legalized gambl and they would try to
explain it to me and I said you guys
going to be lose your allowance and be
broke by the end of the day need two
more
jobs they sucking you in so that was the
reason started not only that I really
believe that the ethics I mean
everywhere I go with my son you met a
mark people hail him you know he's
charismatic he's with the times and I
ask him things we learned from one
another I learned that from my father
nice young man what nice a nice young
man
young gentleman young gentleman yes
there you go and let me tell you
something I thought he was going to be
an Axe Murderer was a kid I was scared
we had to watch him in
shifts the energy of this kid you have
no idea the things he did wasn't bad but
it was creatively a
menace and he got that out of his system
and uh he's gone on to be you know might
my daughter and my son if I wrote down
everything I expected from them
before
they came I would have gotten more and I
did and I'd like to say that I saved
them and uh
I I gave up what I was doing and made
them better people actually it's reverse
I'd probably be in jail dead right now
as we speak and so I ow a lot and that
was one of my father's
values uh getting back to legalized
gambling I'm trying to educate people uh
I usually don't bet because there's no
science in the first three weeks of
football my intuition is still there I
was four out of four the first week
second week I think I was one in one
this week five out of seven that's not
bad some pretty good numbers you know
and if I would have narrowed it down it
would have been one pick that would have
hit each week and that's the way to do
it what's what's the name what's the
name of your podcast again uh taking
action with Chris Columbo it's not just
added stories it's on YouTube YouTube
yes on YouTube uh it's not just that and
you're up with me and so is this other
thing to sit down that was an
interesting interview you know he was
coming at me guns blazing he thought he
knew everything and you know and that's
one thing I learned from my father you
know hold your cool and give him the
facts you know one of the things you
used to say if you're making sense you
don't have to scream and
yell people will hear it you know and
the more they come at you screaming
yelling the more the sense you make and
hold your
composure it's an exchange cuz a lot of
people out of
frustration and you never know what
happened to the person the day before
now me whenever I was in a fight I
always let the person hit me first you
know you can say whatever you want but I
always took the first shot because I'm a
very powerful fighter if I get close to
you it's it's over I don't care who it
is and I never want to unleash that
unless I know I'm in danger I don't
provoke
it but I had a break I'll tell you a
story and this is one of the things I
was
taught so and this is one of the things
you never know what happens to people 10
minutes before and this is what younger
kids are going to watch out for and
everybody cuz people that have a very
bad day or something happened to him my
life I was driving and I guess I pulled
out a little too soon coming out of like
a
a a strip wall onto a three lane main
thorough Fair it was on Route N9 in W
and Falls like it like maybe a half a
second too soon and this guy is on me
beeping his horn flashing his lights I
see him carrying on
so we get to a light he's trying to come
around and I'm not paying any attention
usually at that time you know I'm like
this I'm sorry what am I going to do in
the mirror apologize and he kept coming
now I came to the point it was dangerous
where he's almost trying to run me off
the road so now I says uh I reached my
snapping point you know and we all have
that breaking
point so I get out of the car I slammed
the door I ready open the car and I
ready to just start
and I look there as his wife and I look
in the back seat there's two beautiful
little girls and he's screaming at me I
just listen pull over I says his wife
take the keys away from him I says you
know prob I can't fight with you in
front of your kids if you want to hit me
goad I'm getting back in the car I I
wouldn't do that Jo your wife for kids I
was angry at that point but that's the
kind of self-control and the morals that
were instill to me had that not been you
know what about those two kids watching
me pumble their father
or let's say by accident I slip or he
pushes me in the car hits me those kids
are got to see that for the rest of
their lives and his wife or vice versa
so those morals sto me at that point so
the guy says to me wait you know you
seem like a nice man there a little
picnic bench here he can I talk to you a
minute yeah and his wife says would you
please talk to him and I'm going oh my
God this is so nuts this guy was looking
to run me off the road now he wants to
talk to me so I sit down he starts
crying said I just lost my phone father
the cancer I never told him I loved him
and when I lost him I have this all this
guilt and I have all this anger ped up
so I talk to him I says let it turn to
something else he still hears you you
know it's cuz he's not here that the
matter is is your father he loved you he
understands don't worry about it can I
have your number I'd like to talk to you
from time to time I give my number the
guy still calls me that's great yeah but
the point in the matter is if you behave
like a gentleman you could diffuse a
situation
so those were the kind of things that my
father did now was he the man that
everybody says he was he was one of
probably the toughest men I ever met but
you'd never know it unless you
challenged him but not for money he had
a rule you don't hurt people for money
said it was dirty
paper and one of the things he told me
and he said and was very adamant about
it you can forgive a debt a black guy
he'll heal an insult to go away he says
uh but if you take somebody's life you
can't give that back so even if they do
something deserving of it they may have
a mother they take care of a child an
elderly person or even a cat so death
misery is gone think of that person
before you
act and he said to me he says put a dish
in the stove on broil and he put one in
the
freezer and he says take the one out of
the stove I say I'll burn my hand he
says take the one out of the freezer I
took it out said you can do that that at
any time he says make sure you don't do
things hotheaded and I have a temper
because of the lme disease also whatever
I scream and yell I don't really
anything physically but in an act of of
anger people are capable of things and
if you act like a gentleman both ways
and you have the ethics these things to
escalate and you see it every day in
life you see it on the news people are
just going crazy they're frustrated and
not only that poverty or the need for
money causes people to get
violent so in that era they if they did
numbers or whatever they employed jobs
went back into the
community uh I'm taking action the last
person that I interviewed was making $40
million a year his end with 200 number
stores policy uh that's a lot of money
for 200
locations that's take three they used to
do it with the uh uh pick three handles
the power Mutual they we up three three
different tracks and the total of money
last three numbers and it was the
Brooklyn number of just that track the
paramutual so now they do it with the
ball drop so they would give their
Runners 25% they would employ people in
the store to get significant about 25%
and they would pay $600 to one so if you
hit a number straight for $1 you got
$600 like if you played
355 New York State gives 500s and they
have over 200,000
spots so you can imagine the scenario of
money and they give 6% to the merchant
in the store when you go you see that
machine and and that's and they have to
pay for the machine and they have to pay
for the electric that does that machine
so they're actually at a losing thing
but they didn't have it because people
want it but New York state is making all
the money so the person that's cutting
your cold cuts or putting your money for
gas this person that's got to stop do
the machine they have to pay for the
machine the terminal and it they and
work on a
6% what you called organized crime of
whatever ethnic group was numbers it was
a homegrown Harlem thing you know black
people started it and that money stayed
in the community the runners made money
uh they used to give away food in the in
the and shelter in the number stores
also and they took care of the community
so when take six lotto Mega milons Power
Ball all that came out out it was
supposed to end the number that money
was supposed to be used for children's
education and to lower our tax bills to
keep going higher School tax which are
getting outrageous in suburbs and the
city I have yet to see the tax bill go
on or anything with
education so I don't understand who's
monitoring that and why that money is
not going to the right places and if you
do the comparison I had an expert come
on that's what his name his name was Bob
Hopkins he was making 40 million a year
with 200 stores that was
net and you know I guess he had Partners
or whatever he did but he was considered
the biggest in the five barrows you're
talking about 200,000 spots and not
paying out much at all so I don't know
if there's that much education in the
world so those one of the points that
once the government steps in
administrative course there's got to be
a skim in there somewhere you know and
the other thing is they shut a number
down if you go to play a number and
there's too much on it they know how
much they're going to make you got no
shot to beat them not that you want to
beat them you want to earn a little so
that was one of the points I brought out
and that's one of the points I want to
bring bring out with legalized gambling
there's an estimated 45 million people
are going to bet on professional
football this year and wager
approximately 122
billion now I don't know what they're
pledging for legalized gambling that's a
lot of money
that's a lot of
money so if it does some good for the
community and what's happening is all
this money is not going back into the
community those who had jobs people that
hit numbers people that made money
numbers they bought cars they bought
clothes they went to shoe stores they
bought groceries it's it went back in
anybody knows anything about economics
the tripal backed in with disposable
income it doesn't seem like education
has improved since the lottery took off
no it's gotten worse it's gotten worse
now I don't know the numbers when they
said but they're giving $45 million to
some what but they're giving $45 million
to some guy that was a janitor yeah
yes that's a scary
thing so was it that the government
wanted to control it so they painted
this picture because how could it be
that bad yesterday and this good today
you know like the Catholic Church
Catholic Church says that if you ate
meat on Fridays you went to hell now you
can eat meat on Fridays they let all
those people out of
hellan it's
ridiculous why shouldn't priest get
married they did until the 17th century
I think it's cruel and inuman and uh I
don't like it at all and how could you
trust your children and I and I had
Catholic uh grammar school Catholic High
School and Catholic College how could
you trust and I didn't know and
understand my parents till I became a
father or understand my kids till I
became a parent or what my parents went
through so I I don't know how you could
basically chastise people from having
children I think it's
inhuman and you're allowed to get
married I think to the 15th to 17th
century first priest that died left his
money to his wife he said that was it so
it's a money thing you know it's always
a money thing is always a money thing
always a money thing and I think that's
what people losing sight of now today
you
know and uh you know we go to the doctor
and take awful lot of pharmaceuticals
today I don't do that you know I mean
there's uh uh what do you call it
cholesterol pill any doctor and any
pharmacist takes red rice shees that's
the way Europe we the only country with
a with a cholesterol pill you take red
rice shees goes away but that leads to
another pill leads another pill leads to
another pill and I don't know if they
want to live lead you make you live sick
but they want to make you live on a
pill I mean not too long ago we had the
rock andf laws that you can go to life
get life for marijuana and not even a
large amount now it's the most medicinal
thing in the
world know what's Vice yesterday is
Commerce today again yeah pot is a
cigarette now excuse me pot pot's like a
healthy cigarette now oh it's the best
thing for you I mean it cures everything
they say it does like they did with the
Vapes I mean if you didn't want kids to
take them why would you produce a
bubblegum flavored one and your body is
supposed to the lungs to to purify
carbon dioxide but water it's it
synthesizes it so it's even more
damaging so it's supposed to cleanse air
your lungs I mean it does make it more
filthy with pollution and cigarettes but
with the Vape it's even worse so they
told everybody cigarettes are bad so now
I got kids running around vaping
everywhere you know they always seem to
be the target so moving forward what was
special about Joe Columbo is he
recognize that he knew what was fair and
knew what was unfair he didn't like
drugs he didn't like prostitution he
didn't believe in him because he said
you're living off the blood of people's
children if an adult chooses to do drugs
it's his business or her business and a
woman does what she wants with her body
if a man is making money off that he's
hurting people's children so those are
the morals that I liked about him if you
want to know the truth now you want me
to crucify him for uh being a man or
earning a living during World War II or
feeding his family it's not you're not
going to hear it from me and you know I
don't think there's anything wrong with
bookmaking if there is why is it so good
today that's the way I see it maybe I'm
wrong maybe he's wrong it makes sense
makes sense Common Sense was important
to him I give you a quick story I want
to give you two of them and then we'll
finish it
up the
FBI was working very hard to put my
father in jail it was the coel pro
division of the FBI was seeking
organization the New Yorker leaked it
that's why go to the article on me and
hit toel they put people next to Martin
Luther King uh M an my father and other
people they didn't like you they've
caused violent disruptions within your
organization to make you look bad or
kill you and they're trying to talk
Martin Luther King into uh killing
himself they targeted my father because
he always tried to unite the Italians
the blacks and the Jews because we're
very close in neighborhoods together and
we learned to coexist without prejudice
or malice
and they targeted all three all three
died by
assassination
and moving forward what happened is the
FBI was targeting they couldn't get him
for what they wanted and uh my brother
Joey was a coin
collector and like to collect coins and
at that time a silver quarter which they
were a lot around was worth like 36 or
40 cents so you take them you melt melt
them melt them down you almost doubled
your money and in the late s you know
that was something you could do uh
because you know you know the best suit
you could wear was $40 the best shoes
you could wear at $10 a slice of pizza
was 15 cents you know if you could take
a quarter make another quarter have you
know 100 of them a day you did
good made the the significant money not
money like we see today but the economy
was on the gold standard and things were
reasonable it wasn't inflationary
times so they changed the Lord arrest my
brother Joey and my father was so
outraged he grabbed my mother my sister
and me and he was kicking on FBI
headquarters at 69 Street says take us
all put us all in jail these are gapo
tactics why'd you do this to my son he
was a young man and he was called hobz
act interfering went into State Commerce
he was facing 20 years as a young man
for just smelting down these coins it
was legal yesterday and they CH actually
changed the law to arrest
them and then more people came and more
people came and every night between 300
and 2,000 people would be marching in
front of FBI headquarters and one of
their chance was Heidi Heidi Heidi ho
the FBI has got to go Hitler V he never
di he came back as the FBI and at the
end they would go Zig Zig at 11:00
everybody go home next night they meet
there and the Press would never pick it
up the government to show what was going
along and there were a lot of tactics uh
breaking down doors uh people that were
involved in numbers while they were
laying out there dead they come and
arrest them guns drawn telling the
mother when when the father was in the C
and never seen their son again harassing
pregnant women anything to get you to
get you to be violent against your
family so they could say they got
you so he was he believed in peaceful
protesting so in the course of things I
think this went on for about three weeks
three months excuse me and it was
gaining no traction because news
stations wouldn't pick it up the media
wouldn't write it and the government
used and exercise their rights to do
that illegal rights to suppress it so
out of a turn of events there was a
gentleman a very very strong gentleman
and how this come to be I get a call
from a a a writer and a talk show host
telling me about the Johnny Carson Story
he got some of the facts correctly but
it was distorted he said it was he was
trying to make it in very differently
and he said my father tried to shake him
down for for education for his grandson
my father didn't have a grandson at the
time or granddaughter it was me of
course I was the only uh family born up
state to had me down as they and a
grandchild and what it was he wanted the
news this is what happened Johnny Carson
was at Psy's on the west side not Patsy
in Harlem and Johnny liked to drink and
Johnny liked the woman eyes and Johnny
was Johnny I'm a fan of Johnny's I mean
drinking I've done some silly things
myself in my youth I understand it and
you know he he was a you know he had
quite a uh you know a wit about him was
a very attractive woman and her
boyfriend was a very significant guy uh
he was held as a leader of a crime
family or whatever you want to say he
had that reputation probably one of the
only people that scared me to a story
there as a kid uh this a good
one so
uh one of the reasons I don't C
so what happens
is Johnny's trying to pick her up and
he's you know making comments about her
aess and things like that she moves he
keeps bothering her and uh you know they
got a call of boyfriend's on the way and
the two guys with him finally take
Johnny and throw him down the stairs to
get the hell out of here as said this
guy you know he gets here he does not
tolerate that kind of
stuff the guy gets there here's what
happens he goes to NBC he's banging on
the doors and uh uh he wants to he wants
to get in he tells him Johnny comes back
tell them I'm going to kill them they
shouldn't treat women that way and
people of that
error not just their women all women
they were very particular and of that
lifestyle it was sacred to them that you
didn't act like that and act like that
with them women was really insane I mean
he weren't getting away with they the
life didn't care so Johnny's pretty
upset about the whole situation ation
you know so he goes on the lamb and
people don't know what that means that's
in hiding so he's in a motella New
Jersey and my father was close with a
producer an NBC by the name of sa
Kravitz sa Kravitz if you saw the movie
The Jeff the TV show The Jeffersons was
a popular show at that time there was a
black woman named Rocky Roa Roxy Roker
and she played the beautiful black woman
married to the white guy upstairs and
Jefferson was like the opposite of he
was a black bigot Archie Bunker was a
white bigot he came from that show it
was very entertaining and very typical
of the time and it was reverse satire
yor and it was actually pretty good so
he sa Kravitz married her and had Lenny
Kravitz and his half brother and half
sister is still friends of mine up state
so Ed McMahon goes to SC Kravitz and SC
says yeah I know Joe Columbo he
straightens everything he wonderful to
talk to and here's Ed McMahon he comes
to the house and uh he tells my father
the story my father says
uh okay I'll take care of it he says uh
so my father thinks and he says but
here's what we're going to do he says if
I take care of this because NBC wants
the caution story back you follow me and
uh there a showb and Ed McMahon that's
why he started when Carson Was Out
handling the show without him cuz now
he's gone for quite a some time and the
show is suffering and probably the best
talk show ever I mean I enjoyed it and
uh Ed McMahon and my father became very
close that's how he mced the the two
biggest extravagan of Music put together
Frankie valy Frank Sona try Lopez uh uh
Paul Ana Samy Davis you name it and the
F forum for the Italian American Civil
Rights league and the Inception of that
was this
picky so but they was gaining no ground
so my father says I'll make the deal if
NBC
promises to uh cover the
picking he says and I'll take care of it
they says no problem I think it was
Chris borgan
nice and uh they and they started doing
it that's what happened and uh he goes
and he speaks to this gentleman and he's
being out you know you know he says uh
what are we going to do I don't want to
do this this guy insulted my girl he
says listen he says you never had a
little too much to
drink he said he didn't really actually
touch it did he he says you know so not
only that you show people you're an
animal if you do this right now you're
helping the Italian people gain ground
and you act that way you become typical
of what people are thinking there should
be some forgiveness man and my father
became good friends but one of the
conditions is
that sooner than later Johnny Carson's
got a movie show to California he can't
come to New York anymore so those were
the
terms uh and everything except the
players were correct my father was
correct the Johnny Carson Story was
correct they had the restaurant wrong
and they had the gentleman that they
said did it wrong and he was trying to
put his spin on and he came from
Carson's
attorney to this guy and it was a book
about
Carson so uh even when it was the
upfronts Caron fly in and then fly out
and my father was assassinated 71 Carson
want to get of town soon too anyway
because he didn't have him there and car
and my father met a few times but EDM
and my father became very very close he
was a regular at the house and what a
nice gentleman he was so the second part
is he had me in the school called uh
first I was in Little Flower montor in
Prospect Park with Maria montor is one
of the nuns that trained uh the Indians
with the flowing robes and the bead in
their head they were very Advanced you
had to work very hard it was meant and
people say I'm entertaining
because I learned that there and the
Moni school was to enjoy the work you do
and make it entertaining and fun even
though it may be tedious it may be hard
but make it pleasurable and that's what
I try to do and everything I do do and
that's one of my successes as as a
father I think and they'll tell you I'm
very entertaining with them and so was
my father he made things fun you know
stops being fun stop doing
it so I was in this school was called uh
Berkeley and was all W school so I found
I had a philosophy if you got an A in
conduct a in grades F in conduct you're
in
trouble if you got an F in grades and an
A in conduct you did the best you could
you just didn't have the tools C's and
C's you had to work harder so it was a
pretty good
philosophy so I was getting very bad
grades and I want to get thrown out of
the school very bad conduct cuz every
time I had a good grade I had a fight
every time I good sports I was one of
only two Italians in the whole school
and it was significantly a was school by
Ang sax and
Protestant so I was I was I was uh uh
uh uh diagnosed with
dyslexia now I figured maybe if I I
could do something I what dyslexia was
and you can get out of that school if
you did it so you to give it these
booklets you know they about this big
some were pink some were blue some were
yellow so I started from the back and I
wrote backwards all the way through
right so it look like I had dyslexia but
I had the worst case dyslexia you ever
seen so they invite my father to the
school they tell him you know there's
something wrong with your son he's
dyslexic but they just want to throw me
out cuz there was Italian and his name
was Columbo and he was Hil that's what
he
was and that's what one of the things he
had asked the news to cover with schools
that on
fness so my father gets an expert he
takes me for diagnosis do I have
dyslexia the guy looks this if he's got
dyslexia he's the smartest dyslexic gu I
ever met he says nobody can do this he
says say you want it on out of school he
says you have no idea so he tells the
principal and he gets me out of there
and I go to St Angel's Hall and I never
look back but I knew he wanted me there
and he knows education was important to
him it's one of the things he worked
hard on with the Italian American Civil
RS League also built the camp and uh
Rosen New York for 2,000 under privilege
kids put a handicapped pool in for
children in 1970 that was unheard of and
not by grants or by law and uh those
were the things I liked about him the
other stuff you want to read about him
most of it's untrue but I would have to
say all around he's probably one of the
toughest men that ever
lived but that that wasn't his way he
used his mind not his Brawn and that was
one of the stories to tell and uh you
know IM and Carson became friendly but
him and and McMahon became best of
friends that's why the Carson Show moved
to LA yes yes interesting that was he
can't come to New York acted like that
he said I'm go to California with the
rest of the
weirdos they say he moved and there was
a comment that uh they moved because uh
he want to get better guest and it was
the caution show you know it's like you
saying you you move to Alaska to get
better guest it's not the case and and
actually at that time uh New York was
preeminent people like to come into New
York and uh there was a lot going a lot
more going on than there is
now I think that's a that's one of the
ways that he used his mind and he it was
advanced in in politics uh especially
civil rights and that that was how the
thaan American Civil Rights League
started getting all did they end up uh
uh they end up uh uh what do you call it
they end up uh my brother Joey goes to
trial it's the worst case the federal
government has ever put on because after
they gave their case we gave no defense
it was that bad and within 45 minutes
there was a quiddle across the board so
it it was a and it was recognized and
the lead witness recanted saying that it
was a plot we didn't have to give a
defense what are your biggest regrets in
your
life have two we'll talk about one this
time and maybe another time how's that
excellent you asked me on the land show
have had any gret and no I didn't have a
choice
and I thought about that because you
don't have a choice does not mean you
don't have a
regret there was a friend of mine his
name was Caesar moo and how we became
friends is I failed in uh algebra in
sophomore year or freshman year going
into sophomore I know was 1977 that
summer I was turning I was born October
196 I would have been 16 and dried so I
remember somebody else in summer school
used to pick me
up so I used to get picked up and it was
a school school I was going to was
called John esberg Catholic High where
my children go very good school good
people uh Faith and family is their
motto and we get there and usually
algebra teachers really don't use
algebra for anything and it's really
boring and the teachers to teach it are
really boring too because you never use
it it's not exciting it's not anything
so the teacher that was teaching was a
guy by the name of brother Anthony Duo
and I saying I'm in the summer school he
says I hate this algebra and he walks in
he says he says I know this sucks that
you got to be here for the summer he
says I'm a mad teacher I don't like to
teach alra it's boring to teach he says
I'm not going to give you homework it's
the summer I'm not going to test you all
I ask you to do is pay attention the
time you're here with me I'll ask you
questions what I doing with paying
attention I don't give A's everybody
gets a B I said this is my kind of deal
I said I can pay attention I'm alert no
homework none of this nonsense figuring
out problems this is good so I'm sitting
next to a kid and uh he was a little bit
older and he just wouldn't be
quiet
and brother Duo says asked me a question
I couldn't pay attention because of him
not I'm not going to say he's talking or
being distractive I said I apologize I
pay say you know you're going to end up
back here again that's the last thing I
wanted I asked you to pay attention he
said at least you can give me that I'm
like I want to tell him I'm the biggest
fan of this but I don't want to be able
to teach his pet or telling anybody so I
tell could you do me a favor and please
just be quiet I says could you do that
you guys from the city this that he my
mother's the mayor of Warwick and you
don't understand what trouble I'm going
to cause for you now nobody tells me to
be quiet I oh God look at this Carry On
and On he says and when we go outside
I'm going to kick the hell out of you he
says if you really think you can be my
guest I warn you you put your hands on
me there going to be a
problem so I guess he goes he makes a
phone call so I walk outside I'm not
even thinking about fighting I'm
thinking about getting to the car and
getting out of there as fast as possible
because this guy has something wrong
with him so we gu he says you wait here
my friend chesiree is on his way so
Caesar was a guy very very big guy built
like Babe Ruth and his Caesar or chz his
last name was moo who he saw an Italian
his parents were Italian immigrants and
it comes back that my my father and
brother had a place called katana cloes
the father's name had Primo coats they
were twins so Primo means first and
Italian sandoo means second so his
father was born first named the Primo
the second baby came sugundo for first
and second so I didn't know we had
history so I see a car there was a ramp
coming off the main Highway into the
parking lot of the school and it was
like a Delta 88 that time that was like
the caddy cville or whatever it had the
the spoke rims and was all uh kened up
was the the the termin that you want
look like
yeah Jumping Jack Flash blasting and the
car pulls up and the window comes down I
must have got hit with about 40 PBS of
pot smoke gu I was in London and he's a
driving the car PDD another
license place so Cesar puts his it over
he says you Chris he says
yeah you don't look like you belong here
this mury he says uh he wants me to
fight with you he says I'm a lover not a
fighter he says let's be friends so we
became the best of
friends and later on when I started
bookmaking Cesar was from the Bronx
Williamsbridge Road and he was to hang
out there with a group of his friends
and he became a runner for me later on
because he started gambling so much he
became I put him in the office with me
because if he was sitting there he
couldn't gamble so I F try the other
side of it and he had a friend that was
uh a White Plains cop name was James D
Maria
awful human being he's in jail for a
very long time I hope to see him when he
gets out so anyway long story
short this kid was dealing cocaine to
all his friends the fa Tavern on
Williamsbridge Road that that was his
place and I never really got along with
this kid I didn't like him and CES grew
up in that neighborhood but then his
mother and father got elderly and they
moved up state by me
and one of the offices we had was on
Pauling Avenue in the Bronx and Caesar
lived there uh you know ni say I paid
for it and once in a while we take
action out of there that was our office
and maybe taking action it was a wire
room when there was not much going on
because it made no sense for him to get
up and go they only came and arrest
you at that period of time this James D
Maria was tuning him up and become an
informant got caught dealing heroin and
cocaine in large
quantities and to help get himself off
one of the things he did was told Caesar
that his his uh wife and him arguing
could he stay at the apartment was to
track
me and he was tuning Caesar up with the
coke pretty good and Caesar would come
he was looking worse and worse and he
was broker and broker and I making 75
8,500 a week what are you doing besides
the other money do from from the sheets
and stuff so somebody tells me he has
this guy living there and the guy was
living there inform on me to get my
gambling operation but meanwhile he was
a heroin and cocaine dealer and was also
dealing
arms uh to to to drug uh consortiums
with silencers and machine guns to a
partner of his I never liked this kid
so long story
short uh I tell Caesar to throw him out
of the place I have words with him and
it was I never forget it was the night
of the final four March man it's the
last
game and we used to talk pay phone the
pay phone so you know they didn't have
Taps and stuff and cell phones were just
becoming good and we also had analog
ones that were were were encrypted and
and and scrambled to each other very
expensive but once they weren't digital
we couldn't use them
so the story goes like this this kid was
now going to be brought forward to
testify so he didn't want to do that cuz
he played a tough guy in one of these
gangsters or whatever so he's kind of
like hiding out and I guess he gave CES
the money used to play numbers and used
to get credit and the bodas to play the
number pick three and he hits really big
Caesar the kind of guy to forget to do
things I think he gave Caesar the money
to play the number Caesar forgot so I
never forget he was in the Hawaii sea in
uh in in uh Mars Park and I talked to
him cuz every Monday he would come up
and uh we would go over to work and the
figures and everything and then we watch
Monday Night Football together after the
office Clos he would come
up so they was talking I'm going to be a
little lady says James want me Jamie
wants me to stop in 1922 Fowler and see
him he said what does he want there for
I don't know it's a dark Drey Street and
we hang up and I call back and he
wouldn't answer I said oh
something's bad see I felt it you know
when you feel it
and uh whatever happened only those two
know but uh that's the
theory so he shot Caesar through the eye
in a cowardly fashion he got on the
passenger side and he took whatever his
money out of from in Cesar had bought a
a bu Park Avenue for his mom and he was
driving it and he kicked him out he took
his car left him in the street took his
money and there was only a check that
was made out to me so I went over the
wire it was made which brought me a
tremendous this amount of
heat and I got everybody all night
looking for him and I knew it was bad
because he never missed an
appointment so I I go to the Bronx I'm
looking we find out he got shot I talk
to a detective I make my brother and my
nephew go see his mom which lives close
to me up state so they break it to her
naturally the police come and they're
trying to blame me for it they search
the house she allows them they put her
in the head that I did this and we had
just buried his father and one of the
reasons he was working for me and we
kept him in the Bronx his father was in
a nursing home he was an only child and
they were considerably older for than
the average person that would be have a
child that
age and uh we just buried his father I
paid for the funeral he took that very
very hard and he was going back and
forth taking care of his mother and
staying in the Bronx taking care of his
father in the nursing home down there
and
uh and when the father died he took it
hard it was same funeral so I went to
the the funeral home that was laying the
out and actually out of an autopsy so
toal time cuz it was a homicide and he
was so strong and he was so big and he
was the most
lovable
childlike Sports loving love to eat love
to smoke PL just got caught up with too
much cocaine person you ever met in your
life I mean just not a bad bone in his
body not a vicious bone and uh I spent
the whole night because it was usually
they lay out to your right side and wake
at Catholics so I spent the whole night
massaging his face to bring the swelling
down he didn't even blink when it went
in there when you get hit it swells that
part of your face up so I got it to the
point where we could reverse the
casket and lay him out so his mother
could have an open casket and I had not
seen her yet because I took care of all
the arrangements and I paid for the F on
I supported her for a very long time and
this is how much she loved meemes was
heartbreaking so when she walked up and
saw it was an only child she was
screaming my baby she actually pulls him
out of the cof and tries to drag him
home I never saw
anything including the bad thing I saw
my father that affected me so much so I
don't know if that's a regret and I
thought I was saving him by putting him
on the other side of gambling I don't
know if the drugs got him or just a bad
informant that allowed to do these
things I think they get away with it so
after she did that I sat down I talked
and there was a ton of people at the
Wake he was beloved you know he was a
character you know the Damon runan
fashion and without malice do anything
for anybody and he was a strong strong
guy he talked like he had a gangster
Courtney stro he talked he like that he
was funny he had a good sense of hum
used to tease him and uh but never
committed a crime except bookm with me I
made him a
criminal so
uh his mother the second thing that I
never forgot she says to me you better
get out of here the police are going to
arrest you because they filled her head
up with that I did it
and I thought that she thought that but
later she found out I didn't the guy
that did it at this trial mentions my
name 139 times like that justified
killing him in a cowardly fashion and
actually the the the the police that
were backing him as their hand
was uh when he went rogue wanted to get
him so they went to a kid and they told
him this is the guy says you remember me
you saw machine guns to be Jamie
introduced
you and he says he was an informant so
he calls his wife saying he has money
from this kid and that's how they find
them they arrest him but the the regret
is that a mother lost a
son I couldn't help him and those
memories to this day haunt me
terribly uh I wake up at Nightmares From
it and there are times I wake up crying
from it I mean it was one of the closest
people I loved in my life that was shot
by a cowardly
fashion and if one thing she young kidss
got to learn out there is these guys
that act violent and talk tough
sometimes they got a back door out like
he did or thought he did but he went a
little too far cuz he had nothing to
give him and me as a bookmaker wasn't
enough but I lost a friend and she lost
the only thing she had in her life I
mean I supported her forever uh we used
to play her birthday 3 27 when I used to
play it and still hit it I bring it half
the money besides take care of it you
used to say but nobody would know you
hit this I said I know and we always
Partners in
it and uh that that's one of my biggest
regrets I couldn't save them
or I never think that I had anything to
do with it because the gambling and the
drugs were two different
worlds and I was putting him in rehab
that night and this animal was laying
there and tuning him up on coke
constantly and it was really
bad and if you ask me that's one of my
grants that's one of the things that
haunt me
and that's a a a flame I can't put out
so part of the things I'm doing is maybe
I could save that Caesar for someone
else and what I'm trying to do mhm
gambling comes all good you understand
and violence is no good you know
somebody breaks in your house wants to
hurt you and you kill them I mean I mean
they're going to kill you I mean it's
what has to be done so um and that which
adds to the story about losing your
temper
and what my father said think about she
lost everything she
had and screaming bring my baby home and
he was a big guy you know strong natural
athlete you know everything she had was
taken there was nothing I could do to
replace it that goes back to my father's
morals and it kind of crippled a part of
of of me
forever
all right Chris thank you so much for
more of your stories that was amazing
yeah was it good this time you're always
interesting